[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
investigators go inside the fireplace
where prosecutors say chandler haldison
burned his parents bodies it smells like
barbecued pork oftentimes or the grease
that you would get from barbecuing a
pork shoulder and the murdoch murder
mystery will the disgraced south
carolina attorney be granted a lower
bond plus nearly four years after the
parkland school shooting accused shooter
nicholas cruz is set to be sentenced for
the crop but first the wisconsin man who
purchased a gun for kyle rinhaus takes a
plea deal what his attorney tells law
and crime network law on crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin the friend of kyle rinhaus who
bought the then 17 year old in ar-15 got
a deal from prosecutors where felony
charges were dropped now we're learning
how the deal came together law on
crime's angel levy is here with what
dominic black's attorney is saying
anjanet
brian dominic black faced the
possibility of 12 years in prison had he
been convicted of those two gun charges
related to buying kyle rittenhouse that
ar-15 but rittenhouse's acquittal and
the fact that judge schroeder dismissed
one of the gun charges against him
really called into question whether or
not black's case could or would go
forward you may recall that dominic
black testified for the state against
kyle rittenhouse at his trial he said
the two of them were like brothers and
were together every day for months
leading up to the day of the shooting
black said he bought the ar-15 for
written house in may of 2020 because
rittenhouse wanted one but they agreed
the weapon would stay at black's home
until rittenhouse turned 18.
then the two went to downtown kenosha to
help guard a car source car lot that
night in august of 2020 and rittenhouse
took a medical bag with him as well
that night rittenhouse shot three people
wounding killing two of them rather and
wounding a third the jury found that
written house acted in self-defense now
black's attorney tony cotton talked with
me about how he was able to get a deal
where his client went from facing two
felonies in the possibility of prison
time to paying a fine and pleading
guilty to the equivalent of a citation
number one dominic did testify he did
the right thing he was subpoenaed he
honored that subpoena and he testified
um the other part of your question
whether mr binger reached out to us or
we reached out to him it's a combination
of both um there's a back and forth that
really takes place in every criminal
case here in particular we needed to
wait until the written host matter
resolved before we could have um more
substantive discussions about exactly
what the contours of any resolution
would look like
once kyle's case was done um i reached
out to mr binger he reached out to me on
other occasions and uh we were able to
fashion a deal that
assured dominic wouldn't have a criminal
record that was really the most
important thing from our perspective was
making sure that he didn't have a
criminal record because he has such
exceptional opportunities in his life we
didn't want him saddled with a criminal
conviction
now judge schroeder dismissed that gun
charge against kyle rittenhouse because
he said that the length of the barrel of
the gum didn't make it illegal to
possess for a 17 year old in the state
of wisconsin
dominic black would like to join the air
force and it will it'll be interesting
to see if he eventually does so brian
thanks angeanette joining us today is
criminal defense attorney adam konta and
terry austin adam is this the right
outcome for black if you were his lawyer
what would you be advising him
i would have advised him to take that
deal as fast as his little legs could
have run him to the courthouse to take
it i mean he's going to walk away he was
facing felonies and 12 years in prison
realistically even if he didn't get the
12 years in prison maybe some uh and
this walks him out the door no criminal
record no prison time no nothing this is
just like an enhanced parking ticket
essentially go take it get on with your
life that's what i would have told yeah
deal with a lifetime especially when
you're considering where he started off
terry so how does this sentence that
black took work exactly
well it's an automatic under this
agreement he's agreed to plea
no contest to contributing to the
delinquency of a minor and as everyone
has said this is a non-criminal
violation and judge bruce schrader he
accepted the plea he imposed just a fine
of two thousand dollars and then he
basically dismissed uh the misdemeanor
gun possession charge now essentially
black has no criminal record he's
initially been charged as adam just said
with two counts to sell a dangerous
weapon that's all gone he can go home
now he pays this fine he has no criminal
record and he hasn't violated any felony
statute so i think it was an excellent
deal yeah no criminal conviction i know
in some states depending on the level of
charge you can actually have them wiped
from your record altogether i know in
new york it's like disorderly conduct
gets
sealed after a year we'll see if that
happens here with mr black and jeanette
kenosha d.a thomas bringer referred to
black buying the weapon as a straw
purchase what does his attorney say
about the purchase
you know it's interesting because thomas
binger made that claim again in court
during the hearing in which dominic
black's attorney said he would enter
into this plea agreement he said this
was a straw purchase and tony cotton
says under the law and under judge
schroeder's ruling it was not a straw
purchase and that he could you know
essentially legally purchase that gun
for kyle rittenhouse and that kyle
rittenhouse was allowed to legally
possess it because of the length of the
barrel of the gun so he doesn't believe
that
dominic black engaged in a straw
purchase as we know them yeah i would
agree that's how the law planned out but
it's going to be interesting to see how
the legislature in wisconsin maybe goes
back to readjust those numbers for the
length of the barrel we'll see if that
still maintains not being a crime in
wisconsin
and in wisconsin a man accused of
shooting and killing an immigration
attorney is facing a more serious charge
just one week before his trial is set to
begin theodore edgecombe is now charged
with first degree intentional homicide
after allegedly shooting and killing
jason clearman last year in milwaukee
and what please call a road rage
incident at the final pre-trial hearing
monday the judge granted the state's
request to upgrade edgecombe's charge
from first-degree reckless homicide the
judge also denied the defense's motion
to ban the use of the term victim when
talking about clearman after the judge
referred to the cal rinthouse case where
that judge banned the word edgecombe is
claiming self-defense the judge said the
jury will decide if clairman was a
victim of self-defense or homicide
prosecutors say the shooting happened in
september of 2020 after an argument
between the two men on the road the
defendant's defense team argues video
footage shows the clearman car trying to
run edgecomb off the road that video
then shows clearman get out of the car
that's when edgecomb shot him
prosecutors say edgecombe also fled the
state he was arrested six months later
in kentucky
still ahead on law and crime daily
accused parkland school shooter nicholas
cruz appears in court weeks before he's
set to be sentenced but first the latest
twists and turns in the so-called
murdoch murder mystery what a judge
rules after the disgraced attorney once
again asked for bond to be lord
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
please say two more victims are tied to
the so-called shopping cart killer
bringing the serial killers total to
five women killed investigators say
35-year-old anthony robinson met his
victims on dating websites and lured
them into motels he later killed them
and used shopping carts to move their
bodies in november he was charged with
killing two women last week
investigators found another woman inside
a shopping cart covered with a blanket
they believe she is robinson's latest
victim in a press conference officials
say they searched through thousands of
paper receipts of an alexandria virginia
motel linking the most recent victim to
robinson officials say multiple law
enforcement agencies are working on the
case
robinson is awaiting trial for the
murders of two women in harrisonburg
virginia
he transported the bodies of these women
in a shopping cart
we believe he transported at least one
of our fairfax county victims in a
shopping cart as well
to learn more about robinson we have
solicited the support of the fbi's
behavioral analysis unit and the fbi's
washington field office
we've also partnered with authorities in
robinson's home state of new york
and the harrisonburg virginia police
department
additionally we are working on a
victimology profile and hoping to get in
contact with other women
who may have interacted with robinson
investigators say robinson may have
contacted other women via dating apps
they ask anyone with more information to
contact the fairfax county police
department
on to the latest developments in the
murdoch murder mystery after a request
to lower the bond for disgraced south
carolina attorney alec murdoch a judge
leaves the decision hanging monday
afternoon the former lawyer faces about
50 charges for alleged financial crimes
last month murdoch's bond was set at
seven million dollars a judge decided
the 53 year olds would have to pay the
full amount to get out on bond instead
of the typical 10 percent at a hearing
on monday murdoch's defense and the
prosecution called several people to
testify about the request to lower bond
one of murdoch's former clients
lieutenant tommy moore told the court
that murdoch stole 100 thousand dollars
from him that was meant to pay for
medical bills at the end of the hearing
judge allison lee said she would
consider the request and release a
written order with her ruling murdoch is
accused of stealing more than six
million dollars from a dozen clients he
represented in civil cases he also faces
insurance fraud charges after confessing
to hiring her hitman to kill him in an
attempt to leave a life insurance payout
of 10 million dollars to his son buster
murdoch is also a person of interest in
the double homicide of murdoch's wife
maggie and son paul from june 2021.
back to break down bond requests are
criminal defense attorney adam konta and
terry austin terry what do you imagine
the judge's decision will be and will it
get murdock out of jail pending all of
these potential trials you know i don't
think the judge is going to lower that
bond and i don't think murdoch is
getting out of jail anytime soon i mean
just based on the testimony of those
victims it was heart-wrenching murdoch
faces dozens of charges as you said in
connection with multiple clients and
stealing from your client is
unconscionable i mean as an attorney you
are sworn under an oath to abide by the
law and you have a fiduciary obligation
to protect your client and murdoch did
just the opposite of that not to mention
brian he is implicated in the murders of
his own wife and son so i don't think
he's going to see the light of day for
those reasons i think the judge is going
to decide not to lower that bond
yeah adam uh to terry's point i think
murdoch literally violated every rule of
ethic a lawyer could come across are
there even arguments the defense can
make to reduce bail or is this a lost
cause
well it's interesting the arguments they
seem to be making is that he doesn't
have any money but his bond of 7 million
is so high
and this is someone i argue all the time
that bail should be lowered because
don't you can't judge someone's criminal
record it's will they come back to court
or not well this is a guy who literally
has unknown hidden assets that he stole
from clients has shown that he may
commit suicide or just up and leave i
think he's a high high high flight risk
so any bail reduction at all i think is
going to be minimal if any uh i think
there's no further more more poignant
arguments his defense attorneys can make
and i just don't see anything happening
that's going to get this guy out of jail
all right as the judge says they will be
giving a written order and when we get
that we'll make sure to give you the
update and this the murdoch murder
mystery coming up on law and crime daily
the jury hears experts testimony as
chandler halderson stands trial for the
murder of his parents plus accused
parkland school shooter nicholas cruz is
back in court why the prosecution
requests a delay only a month away from
his coming sentencing
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury bonus
[Music]
welcome back tuesday morning prosecutors
asked the judge to delay the penalty
phase again for nicholas cruz the man
responsible for killing 17 of his
classmates and teachers nearly four
years ago at a high school in parkland
florida on february 14 2018 cruz carried
out the deadliest school shooting in the
country when he opened fire on students
and staff at marjory stoneman douglas
high school 17 people died and 17 others
were injured this past october crews
pled guilty to 17 counts of first degree
murder and 17 counts of attempted murder
cruz's penalty phase is set to begin
february 21st his defensive team once
again said at a hearing tuesday morning
that they will be filing a motion to
remove the death penalty from the table
at that hearing prosecutors said they
won't be ready for sentencing saying
that they haven't received enough
information from experts who are
expected to testify
we've been ready every time on the gilt
phase uh we haven't received the
material we can't take their depositions
uh you know it's the first time we're
ever moving uh for a continuance
i don't see how we can be ready on the
21st and the defense and i understand
this they're still taking depositions of
our witnesses
well mr satz i don't intend on
continuing this case any further out uh
we just do jury selection those uh three
days a week so that you all have the
thursday and friday of those two weeks
in february that's fine
but if you think you can't be ready
because of something the defense is
doing or not doing then please file a
motion but i'm not continuing it any
longer
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney adam conte and co-host terry
austin to discuss cruz's sentence
terry why the rush why do you think the
judge isn't giving the lawyers more time
i love the judge's disposition here i
don't think she should give a
continuance listen like you said it's
been nearly four years since this mass
shooting and there have been delays
already because of covet they can't you
know the case has got to get moving
that's what the judge wants to do here
to see the penalty phase get started she
doesn't want to put over again any more
delays in this trial so you know the
other issue here brian is that these
families deserve justice it's you know
months since cruz has pled guilty and
his attorneys have had an opportunity to
prepare they know who the experts are
they can take these depositions and
there's plenty of time so i agree with
the judge i think she should just keep
this moving just to have some
consolation for the victim 17 killed and
17 injured
now out of how big of a sentencing
hearing do you think this will be what
do you expect with all of these
potential
experts yeah this is interesting to me
because all we're really talking about
here is the death penalty right this is
just a state
where a lot of people really love the
death penalty and some people don't
and so that's why you know why why
wouldn't this just be okay
life without parole
done deal you're gonna spend the rest of
your life in prison you have no chance
of ever seeing the light of day again
perhaps you'll go to a mental hospital
if you're cured from your mental defect
then you'll go to a regular maximum
security prison
i don't understand the point of what's
about to happen which i think is going
to be a very involved hearing with
experts talking about mental health and
effect on uh the effect on him and and
all these other outside factors it just
seems so simple to me and maybe i'm just
not looking at it at the at a in a
lawyerly way maybe i should be looking
at it like with through the eyes of an
attorney but just let's take common
sense for a minute put him in jail for
the rest of his life nobody has to
suffer anymore the judge can be done the
prosecutors can be done and we can all
go home and start moving on with our
lives i agree adam but that may be the
new york lawyers in in both of us and
agreeing there where florida as you said
operates a little differently but we'll
see as this sentencing phase continues
for nicolas cruz when we come back we
head to wisconsin where chandler
halderson stands trial for the murder
and dismemberment of his parents that
what damning evidence investigators
found while searching the family home
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
experts take the stand in the case of
wisconsin versus chandler halderson
telling jurors that investigators found
bone fragments in the family fireplace
prosecutors say twenty-three-year-old
chandler holderson murdered his parents
fifty-year-old bart and
fifty-three-year-old crystal harderson
in july twenty twenty one after that
they say halterson cut up their bodies
and attempted to burn their remains in
the family fireplace halterson is also
accused of scattering body parts of
their parents around southern wisconsin
hollison reported his parents missing to
police and told a similar story to local
tv stations at the start of the week two
experts told jurors they'll hold us in a
family basement and fireplace tested
positive for blood spatter on tuesday an
arson specialist described what he found
in the hollison family fireplace and why
the smell lingered with him
was there any sort of scent that made
any uh that gave you any impression or
that that raised your attention at all
yes there was tell me about that i
equate that smell very often because i
love to barbecue it smells like
barbecued pork oftentimes or the grease
that you would get from barbecuing a
pork shoulder
and
this is the smell that i associated with
what i was gathering from inside that
fireplace when i was down in front of it
and working near it there's a white area
in the middle of that burnt uh
log did that at all catch your attention
yes it did why in looking at the uh the
the burned piece of wood in the center
and the white item that is present there
at about the six o'clock position
uh when we before we moved this out of
the fireplace we took a look at it with
some better lighting and based on my
training experience that appeared to be
bone okay burned bone
adam gory details out of the chandler
trial i think a few people may stop
barbecuing for a while is the defense
doing anything to persuade the jury it
wasn't him though
nothing no
uh and in a longer form uh
no
uh they just haven't done anything yet
you know we'll see when it gets to the
closing you know this is just one of
those cases that they're gonna have to
put it together in the closing and just
point to the prosecution and say
look at their look at their evidence it
didn't meet the burden of beyond proof
beyond a reasonable doubt
but my god there is a lot of evidence
and there is only one logical suspect so
what they have to do
is overcome logic and have they done
that yet i don't think so every you know
i've been watching along on this trial
uh
listening to an officer today described
that the searches that they did i
thought was really powerful testimony of
going through and digging out the weeds
and sifting through the weeds while
they're searching the ponds they're
laying their case and we say this a lot
brick by brick
but i haven't seen the defense put any
dynamite in that wall just yet
absolutely now terry i have to assume
that when or if chandler gets convicted
these details are what's going to be the
issue when against him having the
harshest punishment right
absolutely and i couldn't agree with
adam moore there's no question that this
evidence is stacked up against this
defendant he is definitely guilty it's
not going to be if it's going to be win
and when they find him guilty it's a
question of how long it's going to take
them but he is going to get the harshest
penalty he is now facing obviously first
degree intentional homicide and in this
state he could serve the rest of his
life in prison so that's what i expect
we'll see how this continues thank you
both and thank you for joining us here
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
you